hello everyone uh
my name is uh yannick delphi i'm the
scientific fire manager
at buy nano and i will be your host for
today's events featuring
dr eric le tuze from the goddardly
research center in paris
um i could not wish of a better speaker
and a best
illustration of what by nano can offer
to the field of
cancer research i would like to remind
everyone that this event is uh
interactive please ask as many questions
as you want during the presentation
and to do so simply type them into the
ask a question box and click on the send
button
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
and we will also be conducting a survey
at the end
but before getting started um i would
just like to take a few minutes to
introduce you to uh
by nanos technology um by nano brings
you the true
structure of a genome cancer genome is
probably
the most difficult material you can work
with
as it is heterogeneous highly rearranged
and extremely complex and despite
decades of improvements
in next-generation sequencing is still
not sufficient to give you a clear
picture of how these
genomes can be rearranged electricity is
still
far from it and it's uh
pretty easy to uh to understand when you
take into account that
two-thirds of the human genome is
repetitive making it extremely
challenging for
algorithm to reassemble the roots in
this region
a consequence is that many structural
variants will remain invisible to these
technologies and getting rains of
several dozen kbs using language
sequencing is an improvement for sure
but if we go back to the heterogeneity
problem
the coverage is the key and when you
want to address
highly heterogeneous tumor with a clonal
population
what's the point of spending tens of
thousands of dollars in sequencing if
you just get a fraction of the
information you seek
um this is how in
in 2020 that the uh the the
identification of clinically
relevant structure variants such as bcr
abl translocations
uh are still done by classical
cytogenetics because looking directly
at the dna molecule remains what is the
most reliable
and cost-effective in the clinical
setting
and this is exactly what bynano does we
are not based on sequencing
but just like you would do with scar
typing we directly visualize
extremely long dna molecules and instead
of using a microscope we developed a
super powerful scanner
allowing you to massively image millions
of single dna molecules in parallel
in nano channels we produce the
instruments the sapphire we also have
the chips to linearize the dna
we have kits for dna extraction and
labeling
and our own free analysis tools called
bionano access and solve
let me explain to you how it works in a
few
in a few slides as i told you our
technology relies on the direct imaging
of ultra-long dna molecules
that's why we developed the protocol
where we
lyse the cells in solution and then
we're using a nanobind disk
we tightly bind the dna to that disk
protecting it from
any mechanical stress and now you simply
wash it
elude it and it is that simple
the protocol is fast and perfectly
automatical
note that ffp sample are just not good
enough to be used with
by nano as the fixative will shred the
dna molecule
uh but we do this with the fresh frozen
material
no problem with the the frozen material
uh blood
650 microliters blood marrow aspirate
same
cultural cells fresher frozen 1.5
million
and fresh of frozen tissues or biases
from as low
as 10 milligrams um when we say
long we minutes as our molecule have a
an average length of about 400 kb and
all the way up to megabase
and that's another order of magnitude
compared to what
long-range sequencing can do
once we have this uh megabase size dna
the next step is to label it
here an enzyme will recognize a
six-space per motif
and attach a fluorophore directly
to the dna and the dna is also
counterstained with an
intercalating agent and there's no naked
or probe involved here
it's a simple enzymatic reaction
labeling a six-space per sequence
that appears every 6 kb on average and
the pattern
is unique throughout the genome
then we linearize this dna we use
electrophoresis to pull the dna
into narrow channels that are engraved
on our chips
this is how it looks via electron
microscopy that's what you have on the
top hundreds of thousands of channels in
parallel
the stretch dna is the bottom panel
the blue signal is the backbone stain
with the intercalating dye
and the green you see are the labels we
attached to the dna of through the
genome
and our software tells the different the
distance between the
the labels and we can convert that into
base pair
and the pattern once again is unique
throughout the genome so we know
where the molecule belongs hence the
term optical mapping
now the the instrument will cycle the
molecules into the channels over and
over and
image them over and over until you get
the massive
yields you need to analyze complex human
genomes
you can go up to five terabytes per per
sample
per flow cell meaning that anywhere
between 100x
and 1600x coverage for the same price
the only variable being the time you run
the instrument
once we we collect these images the
software will perform at interval
assembly of the molecules and this is
uh probably the most important step we
align
every molecule we image based on the
label pattern
the general aspect is important because
when you work from a tumor material
you do not want to force the assembly to
reference that would not make sense here
because your dna is too rearranged
you would miss out the the real
structure that way
and we build just what we see
and then once we have these maps we
compare it to the reference
in this case the reference is in green
we align our maps into
a symbol to the reference and we look
for differences and in this case you see
a deletion because the space between the
label decreases
in our sample and of course all the
knowledge
of the reference still comes along
meaning that we know where the genes are
because the pattern once again is unique
throughout the genome and we know where
the labels are
so that way we can detect each major
type of
structural variation starting at 500
base pair under both we can detect
insertion deletion very good at rapid
expansion
we detect tendon duplication and
inversion automatically
at 30 kb and above translocation and
inversion are really hard to detect with
sequencing and we are very very good at
it and once again this detection
is done genome-wide and automatically
we also develop a specific pipeline for
complex
heterogeneous genomes that leverages the
tremendous coverage
uh and look at structure variant at the
single molecule level
and this is crucial when you have clonal
population lacking leukemia
this tool is complementary to the
general assembly
and it allows you to detect all
structural variants
at the level of single molecule 5kb and
above
automatically genome-wide down to one
percent allele fraction with a 90
sensitivity and that's a game changer
and no one else can do this
so now you can visualize your genome in
our browser
called binano axis and you can see here
a circle's plot
where each chromosome are shown in a
concentric circle
different type of svs are present as
dots
the purple line in the middle are the
translocation between each of these
chromosomes
if you just click on uh one of these
events you zoom it
to a map where you can see the the map
aligning to each chromosome
so that's a translocation here and
you can also show the molecules imaged
with our system but on top of that
all these vehicles will be filtered
with the control database so you can
just filter only somatic events rare
events that are not present
in the control population and of course
the uh adaptated
sd card can be exported as a standard
pcf file
optical mapping has raised a tremendous
interest in the cancer field
whether it is to modernize half a
century
old cytogenetic methods such as
karyotyping
if it's to quickly identify actionable
scs such as n-track fusion partners
from tumor dna but it also leads to
numerous discoveries of new fusions
never described before
and let me uh let me just show you one
last example
um i'll finish uh on an example of a
comparative study
led by alexander ocean at the radha
medical center in the netherlands they
aimed at comparing the performance of by
nano
against classical cytogenetics for the
detection of
clinically relevant structural variants
in a cohort of
leukemia patients the preprint of this
work is not bioarchive and i really
encourage you to check it out
you can also go on our website to at the
the link to this to this article
um the aim of this work is a term to
potentially replace this very
complicated
cytogenetics workflow you have on the
left
requiring a lot of different
technologies with a more simple one
more automatable and less demanding in
terms of manpower
and by nano has the potential to bring
them all together in a simple
streamline assay the cohort
they studied includes both simple and
complex leukemia cases complex meaning
that they bear over five aberrations
on the right you have a detail of the
average as we can per sample
the taken message of this study is that
this team
is the first one to report a systematic
comparison between by nano alone
and cytogenetics methods and they found
a hundred percent
accordance with the standard care
meaning here a combination of
karyotyping
fish and chromosome array here is an
example of a
circles plot for one of the samples the
penelope
on the right is a zoom on the balance
translocation between
chromosome 11 and 14 and panel c
and these are the detail of the
assembled map and the molecule detail
this is a case of a complex chromosome
eight chromothrypsis structure that was
resolved
in an aml sample the circles plot
illustrate the the shattering of the
chromosome eight
called as uh intrachromosomal
translocation here that's what you see
on the left panel
and you have the detail of the map on
the right panel
and finally this study led to the
identification of
translocations leading to potential
novel
infusions which is extremely interesting
since these are
very important drivers of cancer
development
they identified 23 potential gene
fusions of which only
four were previously observed
this study is still ongoing and they
will include more patients to reach a
cohort of 100
and we are very excited to see the final
results
but now i would like to introduce
our presenter uh dr eric let's use a
leader of the computational center
cancer genome analysis group
at the santo doroche de cabelle in paris
eric and his group developed innovative
computational approaches to extract
biological insight from large cancer
genomic datasets
and his current project involves the
analysis of mutational signature and the
identification of the driver advancing
cancer
and today he will present us the
identification and characterization
of complex structural rearrangements
induced by replication stress
in liver cancer dr earlier to say the
floor
is yours
thank you very much janik so today i'm
going to
first show you how we identified
a molecular entity of liver cancer with
intense replication stress
and then how we used a combination of
whole genome sequencing
and bio nano optical mapping to unravel
complex rearrangements induced by
replication stress
in these tumors
in the lab we work mostly on liver
cancer and in particular hepatocellular
carcinoma
which is the third leading cause of
cancer death
in the world and it has a very diverse
incident in the world related to the
diversity of risk factors
so the main regions for hcc are
southeast
asia and sub-saharan africa due to the
prevalence of
hpv infection together with
exposure to the aflatoxin b1 toxin
there is also a high incidence in japan
and egypt
due to hepatitis c virus infection
in france the major cause of hcc
is alcohol consumption and the united
states
the dominant cause is non-alcoholic
certain hepatitis and other metabolic
disorders
these risk factors uh induce hcc
mostly because they will damage the
liver
leading to a fibrosis and later a
cirrhosis
of the liver and serotic nodules
can evolve to these plastic nodules that
will progressively transform to hcc
and advance hepatocellular carcinoma
but there are other cases in less than
20
of patients have developed on a
non-serotic liver
and one of the mechanisms for that is
the
insertional metagenesis due to different
viruses
of course the most important virus is
hbv
it has been shown that hbv can insert
into the human genome
and when it inserts near an oncogene it
can lead to the overexpression
of the oncogene and cancer development
and in the lab we have identified
another virus
av2 that rarely uh
can integrate in the genome and also
uh lead to the expression of oncogenes
and hcc
development and recently
we identified a new molecular entity of
hcc that develops in non-serotic
patients and is driven by the activation
of two different cycling genes
namely cyclin a2 and cyclin e1
we discovered this subgroup by the
analysis
of 750 hcc with a combination of rna
sequencing
plus whole exome or whole genome
sequencing
with this approach we identified
recurrent events
leading to the activation of cyclin a2
that are summarized on this graph
these events can be a viral insertion
by either av2 virus in orange or
hbv virus in green here each
arrow represents a viral insertion
identified in one patient
but we also identified some recurrent
gene fusions
that are depicted above that also
involves the same engine 2 of cyclin a2
and the functional consequences of all
these events
will be to generate a
truncated cyclin a2 protein
starting at the beginning of exam 3
at methionine 148 or 158
and this protein will be constitutively
active
because it will lack the regulatory
domains
destruction box and ubiquitin domains
that are on the
end terminal part while keeping the
functional cycling force on the c
terminal part so these are new
mechanisms leading to the activation of
cyclin a2
in htc we also
identified recurrent events leading to
the activation of cycling e1
again it can be viral insertions by av2
or
hbv virus or structural rearrangements
up to 50 kb upstream the transcription
start site
and we verified with uh rna sequencing
data
that all these events both in our cohort
and in the tcga cohort
lead to a massive over expression of
cyclin e1
with a full change greater than 100x
these two genes when activated
will define a homogeneous hcc subclass
as you can see on those keys plots
so these are classifications of
tumors in our cohort like affair and the
tcga cohort
and you can see that tumors with an
activation of spectin a2 or e1
are very close at the transcriptomic
level
and define a homogeneous subgroup
this subgroup has also clinical
particularities it is a very aggressive
subgroup
with very dismal prognosis and
uh the hcc and hcc
tumors are also particular
in that they tend to occur in younger
patients
with a non-fibrotic liver and they will
be very big tumors
usually greater than 10 centimeters
at the molecular level this subgroup has
an
enrichment of inactivation of
rb1 and p10 tumor suppressors
and it is uh exclusive with activating
ctn md1 mutations that are frequent
in other htc's now if you look at the
gene expression features um this tumor
subgroup has a strong
over expression of e2f targets that
reflects the
uh very fast cell cycle in these cells
and also it shows a strong
over-expression of
atr pathway that is implicated in
response to replication stress
this can be expected because cyclin e
and cyclin a are both implicated in cell
cycle progression
and more precisely they will cycling e
promotes
s-phase entry and cyclin a progression
into s-phase
and it has been well documented in
several models
that when you activate cyclins a
or e cells will ensure enter
s phase prematurely which leads to a
replication stress
and we wondered if in this subgroup of
tumors
the replication stress that we can
detect at the transcriptomic level
would lead to a particular type of
genomic
instability to assess that
we analyzed the whole genome of a
15 ccn hcc and we examined first
the number of different types of somatic
alterations
here you can see from left to right the
number of point mutations
small insertions and deletions and
structural rearrangements
in a ccn hct versus other hcc
so in terms of point mutations and
in-depth cp and hcc
don't have any particular increase
in terms of the number of mutations
by by contrast they all show a very high
number
of structural rearrangements with on
average
more than 400 events per tumor
so we wondered if this
massive load of structural
rearrangements
could have a specific signature that
could be a signature
of replication stress and to
test this hypothesis we looked into more
details into the types
of structural rearrangements that we
could find in these tumors
when we talk about structural
rearrangements in cancer cells
we can talk about simple rearrangements
with the well-known categories of
deletion
duplication inversion and translocations
that can be
reciprocal or not and as uh mentioned by
yanic there are also more complex events
uh that will um generate a large number
of
abnormal junctions uh in a single
catastrophic event
and the most well-known example is
chromotripsis
where a chromosome or a fragment of
chromosome
is uh broken into pieces into a
catastrophic
event and these species are then
stitched
together but in a random order
leading to the accumulation of numerous
copy number
and abnormal junctions in a single event
what about hcc by whole genome
sequencing we found that on average
uh an hcc displays 50 somatic structural
rearrangements
but the profiles are very heterogeneous
as you can see with those three examples
so here you can see circus plots with
different types of events
represented with a code
the first tumor on the left cfc892
is very quiet with just one
inter-chromosomal translocation
and a handful of dilations
by contrast the tumor in the middle uh
has
a very large non-burden of tandem
duplications in green
and interchromosomal translocations in
grey
whereas the tumor on the right has a
deleted phenotype with a
large number of dilations so this
suggests
that there can be different mechanisms
generating different types of structural
arrangements
that are more or less active in
different
hct and to analyze this
further we used a method
to detect signatures of structural
rearrangements
that is an adaptation of the well-known
method for a mutational signature
analysis
the idea is to split the different
rearrangements
into categories so here we
divided rearrangements by the type of
events
the lessons duplications inversions
translocations
also by the size of the events ranging
from less than one kilobase
to more than 10 megabytes and we
distinguished
clustered from non-clustered
rearrangements
with this approach we could identify six
distinct rearrangement signatures
operative in htc signatures
rs1 and rs2 for example are duplicator
phenotypes
with the prevalence of duplications but
that differ
by the size of the events and also the
rs1 signature comes with
frequent interchromosomal translocations
signature rs3 is a signature of
clustered rearrangements that actually
correspond to
chromocrypsis and then signatures
rs5 and rs6 correspond to a delete of
phenotypes
with different size ranges
next we classified our tumors
based on the number of rearrangements
uh attributed to its signature
as you can see on this clustering
and this allowed us to identify a group
of tumors
that you can see on the left that has
a very high number of structural
rearrangements
several hundreds usually that are
attributed to signature rs1
in dog breed and it turned out
that this tumor this group of tumors
precisely to the ccn htc subgroup
and this led us to conclude that the rs1
signature
may be the signature of rearrangements
induced by replication stress
in cc and hcc
so let's have a closer look now at this
signature
it is characterized by the accumulation
of focal tandem duplications
smaller than a hundred kilobase and it
comes together
with many inter-commodore translocations
it is very easy to recognize in a circus
plot
with these uh numerous direction uh
duplications
in green and interchromosomal
translocations
and it also leads to a very
characteristic topic on the profile
with a high number of focal gains that
are distributed
throughout the genome now we will
zoom into uh the chromosome 14 of this
tumor
to have a closer look at these events
here we are here you can see the
different focal gains
and on the top of this log ratio profile
we ovulate the structural variance
identified by whole genome sequencing
so you can see that some of these gains
correspond
to classical tendon duplication
where a segment here segment b is
duplicated just next to itself
this is an expected structural
rearrangement
leading to a focal gain but we also have
more unexpected mechanisms
where a focal gain is actually
surrounded by
two translocation breakpoints
in this case here going to chromosome 2
and if you go on chromosome 2 you will
see
another focal gain with bordered by
translocation breakpoints going back to
chromosome 14.
so we have here a complex event where
two focal gains on two different
chromosomes
are interconnected by translocation
breakpoints
a mechanism that we called
inter-chromosomal
templated insertion so what could be the
resulting molecule
from from such some events by whole
genome sequencing you can only
reconstruct two possibilities
one possibility is that the segment e
from chromosome 2 is inserted
in the middle of two copies of segment b
inside chromosome 14. and the second
possibility
on the contrary is that segment b from
chromosome 14
is inserted in the middle of two copies
of segment e
inside chromosome two with whole genome
sequencing you cannot distinguish these
two possibilities
because they both respect the
abnormal junctions that have been
detected as well as the
copy number for each segment so if you
want
to confirm the existence of certain
events
and to identify the real molecule
in the tumor you need some long-read
analysis
and that's why we performed an analysis
with bionano optical imaging
we analyzed in this project four hcc
and much normal liver samples the
starting material was frozen tissue with
30 milligrams
and this tissue went through the
protocol already explained by yanic
with an isolation of high molecular
weight dna
followed by labeling with dle1 enzyme
transfer into saphir instruments
and then the the barcode
of the of the labels is read by the
sapphire instruments
and the molecules are then analyzed with
bio nano software to map them
on the human genome and identify
structural rearrangements
first a few technical metrics we did
obtain very high molecular weight dna
from all our sample
except one normal sample for which we
could not provide
enough starting material um on
we have we had for every sample around 1
300 gigabase pairs of molecules greater
than
150 kb
and with an average molecule size around
250 kb so we did
obtain a very long molecule with this
protocol and we were quite
impressed by this because usually with
our extraction protocol
the dna is fragmented in 10 kilobase
segments
on top of that we obtained a very good
coverage with
300x through the genome which is a great
coverage to identify
subclonal rearrangements in tumors
okay so in terms of analysis uh
the molecules obtained by the saphir
instruments
were analyzed by the two pipelines
described by yannick the de novo
assembly pipeline
and the rare variant analysis pipeline
and the particularity of our project is
that we are analyzing tumors
and we are interested in somatic
structural rearrangements
so to obtain these lists of somatic
structural rearrangements
we compared svs called in our tumor
samples
with the matched normal liver samples
to identify svs that are specific to
tumor cells
here are the results um you can see here
the
uh circus plots showing the
rearrangements
identified by bionano optical mapping
in our four tumors we had selected
two tumors belonging to the ccnhcc
subgroup
with replication stress and two tumors
belonging to other
hcc subgroups and you can see here that
with bionano
we successfully i recovered the
rs1 signature of replication stress
characterized by numerous
interchromosomal translocations and
duplications
specifically in the two ccn hcc
i just want to highlight that in tumors
chc 3798
the second tumor from the left the
tandem duplications were very small
so they were identified as insertions in
purple
in most of the cases so overall
uh bio-nano optical mapping successfully
detected
our signature of replication stress in
the two samples where they were
expected
because we also had whole genome
sequencing for three of the tumors
we performed a comparison of structural
variants
followed by short field whole genome and
bionam
i must mention that the whole genome
sequencing we performed
was quite a high depth because we had
90x for the tumor and 30x for the normal
this is illumina sequencing 100 base
pairs
paired and and we call structural
variants with manta software
um here you have the comparison of sv
calls
with all genome sequencing versus bio
nano in the three tumors
the first tumor is a classical hcc
with relatively few rearrangements and
the two others are ccn
hct with a high number of rearrangements
induced by replication stress
in the first tumor we had relatively few
rearrangements with whole genome
and we called a little bit more with
bionano
in the second tumors we could already
see the signature of replication stress
in whole genome
with a large number of translocations
and duplications
but we found even more events with
bionano
for example we had 78 tantrums
applications in whole genome sequencing
versus 127 with bionano
and bionano also calls other types of
rearrangements like
the insertions and intrachromosomal
translocations that do not correspond
precisely to
deletions or inversions in the third
tumor
3798 there was a large number of
duplications
identified in whole genome sequences and
less
in bio nano but this is due to the fact
that
these duplications are very small
and sometimes too small to contain
enough markers to be identified as
duplications with bio nano
and they are called instead as
insertions
so they are identified but the number of
labels
is not sufficient to classify them as
duplications
overall the venn diagrams show that the
two approaches give very consistent
results
with a large number of overlapping
events
but bionano calls extra events
and with on average 1.5 times more
events
identified than with whole genome
sequencing
so the events that were identified by
whole genome sequencing and not
bio nano are often very focal events
sometimes smaller than 1kb and these
events
are difficult to identify with optical
mapping
and by contrast i will show you in the
next few slides
what are the numerous additional events
we were able to detect
on this graph you have a zoom on one
chromosome
with the log ratio profile obtained by
whole genome sequencing
each point is a 1kb window
and on top of these log ratio profiles
we
overlaid the structural variants
identified by whole genome sequencing on
the top
and by bio nano at the bottom
first you can see they are highly
consistent
and then we can have a look at some
events that are detected only with
bionano
some of these events are centromeric and
these regions are known to be repetitive
and very hard to analyze with sequencing
approaches
bionano in turn is able to identify some
rearrangements
in these areas
we also identified many subclonal events
with bionano that were mixed with whole
genome sequencing
simply because the coverage with bionano
is very good with 300x
versus only 90x for whole genome
and finally we identified more complex
rearrangements that were missed with
whole genome sequencing
here the red arrows show you some
inter intrachromosomal rearrangements
that associate together
a different regions on the same
chromosome
and this very complex rearrangement was
missed by whole genome sequencing this
is exactly the type
of events we wanted to characterize in
detail
and because we had identified some
complex events related to replication
stress that we wanted to elicit
and i will now show you
a few typical events related to
replication stress that we could
characterize
index this type of event
i already showed you an example a few
slides ago
is called interchromosomal templated
insertion cycle
here you have two focal gains on two
different chromosomes
that are associated with a transcript uh
translocation breakpoints with whole
genome sequencing we can
only imagine the resulting molecule
and there are two equivalent
possibilities
one in which segment b is inserted
in the middle of two copies of segment a
and the reverse option where segment a
is inserted
in the middle of two copies of segment b
and with bio nano we could resolve this
uh
these two possibilities um here
you can see uh the different molecules
the long molecules that were analyzed
by the saphir instrument um and
so they are in orange and the blue dots
on these molecules correspond to the
marker
of the dle1 enzyme from these molecules
uh bionano could reconstruct a consensus
sequence
the map 4381 that corresponds to
the local region and with this sequence
we can reconstruct
our complex rearrangements here
let's start with the beginning of the
molecule
the barcode of labels fits nicely with
the
beginning of our event on chromosome 3.
later on the molecule the four labels
correspond to the b segment on
chromosome three
and you can see that these labels are
found
at two different places in the molecule
so we can see
the duplication of this region and in
the middle of these two copies
you have another region that this time
aligns on chromosome 1
and corresponds to our segment a
and the end of the molecule is just the
following
of chromosome 3. so with this
approach we can first confirm the
existence
of this inter-chromosomal templated
insertion events
and we can ascertain that the real
molecule
resulting from this event is an
insertion
of segment a into chromosome 3.
with optical mapping we could identify
other classes
of recurrent events due to reputation
stress
and in particular an important class are
intra-chromosomal templative insertion
cycle
this is quite similar to the previous
events unless that the two focal gains
are
located on a single chromosome here
chromosome 10. you can see two segments
one around 79 megabase
another one around 91 megabase that are
both gain
and that are associated with inversion
breakpoints
detected in whole genome sequencing
with bionano we could resolve the
structure of this complex event
and see that segment b is actually
duplicated with an insertion of segment
a
in the middle so we can reconstruct
the molecule resulting from this
rearrangement
where the a segment has been inserted
within two copies of segment b at
position
91 megabase on chromosome 10.
and finally these are events that
involve only two segments but we also
have some more
complex patterns involving uh
up to 10 different segments that can be
located
on a single or different chromosomes and
i will uh
finish with this example here that
involves four different chromosome
segments
that have been gained in a single event
related to replication stress the first
three events
a b and c are located on chromosomes
three
and the last one segment b is located on
chromosome six
and you can see that different abnormal
junctions corresponding to inversions or
translocations
join these different segments
with bionano we were able to identify
some molecules
summing the complete event
and showing that we have an adjacency
of segment c then a then d
and then b and so we can reconstruct
precisely
the complex molecule that
arises from this this rearrangement
wave in the middle of the two b
segments in chromosome 3 you have a
juxtaposition of segments c a and d
but this is quite exciting because with
uh the combination of whole genome and
optical mapping we can reconstruct very
complex karyotypes
at base their resolutions but
the events i showed you are around
between 50 and 100 kb and we sometimes
have some events that involve segments
smaller than that
in which case it can be difficult to
recognize
the region of the genome corresponding
to each segment because you will only
have
very few markers so we are currently
developing
a computational method to
validate some complex events involving
focal segments
uh you have an example here so let's say
you have
four very small segments that are joined
together
and each one just has one or two uh
really one motif then it won't be
possible to
to map them efficiently with optical
mappings
what we will do is we will reconstruct
the candidate molecules based on whole
genome sequencing data
then since we know the dle1 motif
distribution and the genome we can
reconstruct the expected barcode
for each molecule and we will look
directly for these barcodes into the
lung molecules
in optical mapping data to find the
reconstruction that is actually present
in the tune so far
we have been able to characterize
diverse types of structural
rearrangements related to replication
stress with
whole genome sequencing and optical
mapping about
half of the events in ccnhcc are
classical
tandem duplications and
about 40 percent of events
are templated insertion cycles that can
be
intra chromosomal or mode
like i just showed you interestingly
all these events are consistent with
a breaking used replication mechanism
where the replication fork gets stalled
at some point
and we'll jump to another location
either on the same or different
chromosome replicate a stretch of dna
then move back to another region and
finally come back to the original
template
leading to these different types of
complex structural rearrangements
finally we investigated
the location of these breakpoints or on
the genome
to find what features could favor
the blockade of replication fork
and on this graph here you have on the
first line
the density of breakpoints due to
replication stress per 500 kb
windows and you can see that
the hotspots of replication stress
breakpoints
are associated with regions that tend to
replicate
early to have an active gene expression
and active chromatin marks in particular
h3k27 acetylation
which is the mark of enhancer regions
in fact the genome is divided into
topologically associated domains that
are
active or inactive and have a strong
bias
for replication breakpoints to occur
in early replicated active
topologically associated domains
this is a graphical summary
with this study we are able to define
a new entity of hcc representing seven
percent
of the tumors that are initiated by
cyclin a2 or e1 activation
leading to premature asteroid entry
replication stress
and the replication for collapse
followed by breaking news replication
will give this very characteristic
rearrangement
signature that we observed and there can
be second hips
due to these rearrangements and we
identified recurrent
third activating events
and this will give large tumors highly
proliferated
proliferative with a poor prognosis
in but we hope that this subgroup could
be
targeted because the replication stress
may confer vulnerability
for example to park inhibitors or atr
pathway inhibitors
in conclusion the optical mapping
technology allowed us to identify
more structural rearrangements than
whole genome sequencing
to unravel complex events induced by
replication stress
and may be used to identify replication
stress
in clinical samples we found that
replication stress in liver tumors
generates a specific signature
of tandem duplications and templated
insertion cycles
and defines a new entity of hcc uh
with a specific clinical and molecular
features
that may be used for targeted therapy
this is this work was mostly performed
by a phd student contambayar
and the tools we developed for
rearrangement signature analysis
are available in github in our
package called salimpsys and
for to finish i will thank all my
collaborators in jessica ziggman ross's
lab
our collaborators abroad and sponsors
and thank you for your attention
thanks a lot thanks a lot dr jose for
this uh
presentation uh we will now start the
live q a portion of the webinar and
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now you just
click the ask a question box located on
the far left of your screen
and we will answer as many of your
questions we have time for
so um let's um
get started the first
the first question are
all the htc managed the same way whether
they are originating from a thyroidic
liver or from a viral
infection i mean in a in the clinical
way
are they managed the same
the management of hcc depends on the
bclc stage
that takes into account the number the
size of the tumors
and the involvement of um uh
and the insertion into blood vessels
for early stages small tumors can be
offered curative treatments
by surgery or chemotherapy or
radioabolization but for
advanced stages the main treatment the
main
treatments are combination of tyrosine
kinase inhibitors
and immunotherapy are being more and
more
used and regarding cirrhosis
the problem with cirrhosis is that
it will increase the toxicity of
different drugs so the patients who have
a healthy liver or at least non-serotic
can potentially benefit from more
treatment
options than the others and it's um
it's the case for the for this tumor
subgroup that we identified here
okay a second question can
bio nano also predict viral
insertion in the chromosome
um do you want to answer that and um can
probably
get a bit later um so the poor tumors we
analyzed
had some hbv insertions that we
had already identified with whole genome
sequencing
the problem is that the hpv virus is
quite small
and it doesn't contain any of the gle1
marks
so the insertions of the virus are
detected because they will
shift the labels of surrounding human
genomic regions and so you can detect an
insertion
but if you don't know if there is sbb
you cannot
prove only with optical mapping
that this is an hpv insertion
thanks i will just add a little bit to
that there is a non-commercial
option to to do this uh using a crispr
assay that will uh bind to the dna
and light up the sequence that are do
not contain
dla marks so that way you can light up
the telomeres so you can light up
virus sequences for which you design
guide rna4
um can you remind what are
uh what tool did you use for detecting
destructive variants from your
all genome sequencing data for whole
genome sequencing we use the
manta tool that takes
as input the bond files from the tumor
and normal
and identifies the the somatic
structural variants
we are quite happy with this tool
because the structural variants we
identify
usually map very well the copy number
profiles
which gives a positive control for the
for the quality of variant coding
okay well
this approach uh detects any
heterogeneity
in a tumor population i think this
question refers to
um all genome sequencing on one hand
by nano on the other and the combination
of the two
so with whole genome sequencing we can
estimate
the proportion of tumor cells that
contain
each rearrangement simply by counting
the proportion of molecules uh
some genomic region that contain the
rearrangement
versus the total number of sequence
trees
this gives us an estimation of the
the proportion of tumor cells bearing
each rearrangement
we haven't tried yet with bionano data
to do this
but since we also have a count
of the molecules corresponding to both
the rearranged event
and the normal dna sequence i guess that
we could just as well
compute a variant allele fraction and
get an estimate of the clonality
of each rearrangement
just to um to add up to that um
you used a 300x coverage for this study
it was referring to
up to a 1600x coverage on this
new five terabase pair yield that you
can get per sample
is the latest iteration of our
technology that is available since uh
just a few days
um explaining uh how you used 300x
coverage for
for that um is there a way to
uh reconstruct the complex
rearrangements
or has it to be done by visual
inspection
i think you answered this in your last
slide
yes so for complex rearrangements um
i think in bionano software you can
detect when you have
a consensus molecule to
where regions of the genome aligns each
part
uh but uh yes we also did a lot of
visual inspection because it was our
first project with this technology
and like like i mentioned i think
something we added
is that when you have
i think we lost and doctor let us for a
few minutes um
just for the time he uh
reconnects um let me
maybe try to uh to find a few questions
that
are uh referring to uh two by nano
so um we had a question on uh does by
nano
uh detect also ec dna
there was a recent paper um uh
sorry i didn't destroy it recently i
just came back
okay i'm just finishing the question i
was i was answering on the ec dna
uh um we do not detect the the the
sacral structure of the dna by itself
and also because the dna will
break during the the random de-break
during the
the dna extraction but we will detect
all the rearrangements that
are typical for this type of structure
uh
namely uh the large amplifications that
are associated with uh
with this type of ecd in it um i
direct you to our website where we refer
to this paper very interesting paper
on ec dna uh published recently
um to go back to the question with uh dr
mr
um a tumor with a cycling activation
present a
high number of strictly variants iris so
um uh are they acquired in a single
catastrophic event
or does this happen progressively during
tumor genesis
[Music]
sorry i missed the question sorry
the the tumor with the cyclin activation
present a high number
of uh of uh of rearrangements uh are
they
acquired uh um uh
following a dramatic catastrophic event
or all the way
during carcinogenesis okay so
to answer this question we were able to
analyze
for a few cases both a primary tumor
and a relapse a few years after
and in each case we could monitor the
evolution of the phenotype
with the acquisition of additional
events
with the same signature and we also have
in some cases very complex
rearrangements that we
interpret as a templated insertion cycle
reusing the same segments as a previous
one
so i think that the
rearrangements induced by replication
stress are
accumulated progressively during tumor
genesis
okay would you say the the fuel the
tremerogenesis
or the accumulation of events um
is more passenger events leaving
genomics cars
okay so indeed uh you can wonder
if it's the rearrangement signature we
see is just a consequence of replication
stress or if it
plays a driver role in turning genesis
uh
at least we identified one recurrent
event
in third promoter that is uh
significantly
enriched in this tumor subgroup
and uh for these events they definitely
fuel turmeric genetics because third is
a
well-known oncogene in hcc
but we haven't identified uh other
regions that were
altered significantly more than expected
by chance
uh in this subgroup so for now
only the third rearrangements can be
defined as drivers
but we only analyze so far a 15
hcc and htc so i think we need to
increase the series and we might
identify
additional secondary drivers activated
by replication stress induced
rearrangements
okay um what would you say is the
advantage of
combining whole genome sequencing with
by nano versus each methods
individually well i think the
the two methods are very complementary
the strength of whole genome sequencing
is that you can detect the abnormal
junctions at base pair resolution
and but the the weakness is that
you only see you cannot detect complex
events
in their entirety whereas with bionano
you do not have a base pair resolution
but you can really reconstruct complex
events very well so when you combine
both
you can have both the large view of the
of a long molecule as well as the
precision
of whole genome sequencing at base pair
level
okay um i think we have time for for one
last question
i really like the the translational
aspect of your work
more of a comment but when you say that
by nano identifies the the replication
stress signature in your samples
i can help drawing a parallel with the
need of to identify patients eligible to
par benefiters
that present an accumulation of dna
damages in breasts
ovarian prostate cancer to that regard
you you
you mentioned that cyclin activated hcc
may benefit from a tailored therapy
what are your plans to move forward in
this direction
we have two projects going on to try to
to move to
the to the clinic the first is to try to
identify
[Music]
ccn hcc in retrospective cohorts
and to do this we are testing uh
immunohistochemistry
of cyclin a2 and e1 to be able to detect
this subgroup
in paraffin-embedded tissue
and the second one will be to
develop a mass model so we are
collaborating with a team at mount sinai
to develop
a mass model of ct and hcc that we could
use to test
the drugs that seem logical for this
subgroup in particular the atr
inhibitors
that will directly target the response
to replication stress
okay nice uh we still have a 32 and
answer question that we will follow up
by
by email because we're running short of
time uh thank you again
uh dr lutze for your time do you have
any final comment for
our audience well thank you very much
for the
opportunity to give this talk uh
i must say i think uh the structural
rearrangements
will really gain a lot of uh
we we will gain a lot of insights from
technicals such as
optical mapping that is very
complementary with the whole genome
sequencing so i'm
quite excited about this approach
thanks again thank you again and before
we go so thank you
all of you to uh to for joining us today
and for your
question once again the question we
didn't have time to cover today
uh we will be uh submitting
um by by email and we will get back to
to you uh once again i would like to
thank dr
tuse for his time today and his uh his
research and
amazing results uh thank you again to uh
to lab roots for making this uh
this webcast uh possible today um
this will be um open to uh to view
on demand so uh a lab group will alert
you with a
with an email when it's available for
replay and we encourage you to share
with this by email with your colleagues
or people that have missed that event
um a survey will pop up right after
we finish and please answer to
help us improve the webinar program and
until next time
thank you and goodbye